why don't we go next to
oh i don't know um why don't we try
george from chicago
george you're on the air
how's my audio your audio is maybe about
a six and a half seven not bad
oh all right well david
sir oh i'm sorry your audio just dropped
to a five
oh oh geez i'm sorry uh i'll try again
real quick okay yeah please
okay uh david i heard uh uh article in
the comments that talked about um
rising uh or some of the stimulus uh
preventing people from going
into uh the workforce do you think it's
a
little bit too soon to say whether or
not that's a good call to do that story
yet
yeah so i did a segment about this
earlier this week and spent about you
know 10 or 15 minutes talking about it
here's my view on this because i think
this is really important
there it's a very popular right-wing
argument right now to say
because of the enhanced unemployment
people are just raking in money by not
working and so this is causing all these
restaurants to be unable to hire people
and
here's the bottom line enhanced
unemployment benefits uh
and and i think it's september 6th
but it's i believe sometime in september
once that happens
all sorts of people that right now might
be choosing not to go back to work
because if they go back to work they
might make the same or a little less or
whatever because of the enhanced
unemployment
they're going to need to go and get get
jobs they're just going to need to go
and do it unemployment's going to end
and it's very easy to just look at a
social welfare program
and point to what you would consider to
be the free riders or people taking
advantage of it making more off of the
program than from work
but that's going to come to an end
enhanced unemployment was hugely
beneficial to the country at a
macroeconomic level
and in the next three to four months i
believe this is going to resolve itself
george as people are going to need jobs
there's going to be no more unemployment
and some businesses will have to pay
more and there's no question about it
and there is an argument to be made
in some states if you can't get people
to come and work for you
maybe you're not paying a high enough
wage it is true
that dropping enhanced unemployment on
top of state unemployment
distorts the labor market that's
absolutely undeniable
the question is is it exposing
that the wages are too low in some cases
the answer is yes and there's not a
one-size-fits-all answer to that
different states have different minimum
wages but i believe this will be
resolved
by october 15th okay okay thank you i
just thought that article was a little
bit too soon and it lampooned the
stimulus a little bit too much i
agree we're trying to get you just a
real quick question yeah um
i'm going to be through uh uh whether
you call it fortune or unfortunate
circumstances i'd say fortunate
um in boston massachusetts uh next week
anything in particular you think i
should see
have you been to the city before uh no
sir
okay when when i would you know when
people when i was in boston and people
would come visit me if they had never
been before
i would sort of give them a tour that
includes
the popular touristy area of you know
the boston common area
and newbury street along the river
between boston and cambridge
you definitely want to go over to
cambridge check out harvard yard
check out mit check out that area
but then also go down to southie and
dorchester
go to castle island uh go to
some of these other you know new hip
neighborhoods
what else uh yeah i don't know i mean
that's probably already enough for a
weekend
yeah yeah thank you all right uh have a
going david all right george
absolutely uh perfect phone call really
can't we we're off to a great start
today let's see if we can keep it going
one of our sponsors
is magic spoon breakfast cereal
sweet and delicious like the cereals we
loved as
kids but without the sugar and without
the carbs magic spoon tastes
just like those sugary cereal brands we
know and love
but it's only 140 calories zero grams of
sugar only four net carbs and
packed with 13 to 14 grams of protein so
it's perfect for anyone following a
keto or low carb diet or just
anyone who wants to avoid sugar like me
you can choose from flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
blueberry
cinnamon or build your own variety box
if you don't love magic spoon as much as
i do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked
that is how much magic spoon believes in
their product
you'll get five dollars off when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video